from land to river to see the flow of
far too much of our plastic waste a new
report by MPs warns we're treating the
ocean as out of sight out of mind and
it's suffering environmental audit
committee urges the government to lead
global action the ocean is under threat
has never before from climate change
which is warming it and acidifying it
and D oxygenating it it's under threat
from overfishing and it's under threat
from pollution and we're pouring sewage
and chemicals and plastics into our
ocean so we've just got to stop treating
it like a sewer the committee wants a
halt to exports of contaminated plastic
waste to countries with a poor record on
pollution control an issue raised by sky
ocean rescue it also urges the
government to bring in a deposit scheme
on plastic bottles far sooner than the
current plan of 2023 and it castigates
ministers for failing to bring in a
charge on disposable coffee cups on
current trends the amount of plastic in
the ocean is set to treble in just 10
years
and yet scientists still don't know
whether there are long-term health
implications of it being in the human
food chain and piece a far more needs to
be done to stop plastic waste at source
the report says the government is
failing to properly protect marine life
although it claims to have set aside 20
percent of UK seas as conservation zones
just a tiny minority banned fishing with
serious concern over a method called
bottom trawling it scrapes up the seabed
it eliminates the ability of parts of
the fish community to recover over time
doesn't mean necessarily all of this
communities but particularly ensuring a
more rich areas the nursery habitats
that are important for the movements of
fish
the Department of Environment said
Britain has led call to protect 30% of
the world's oceans by 2030 and its
recent waste strategy had included
comprehensive plans for tackling the
scourge of plastic but there is far more
that needs to be done to protect the
world's oceans Thomas More Sky News